paul einer der ja ebenfalls immer für
strenge corona maßnahme plädiert ist ja
auch spd-gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach der ist ja allerdings ein
spacken wie fdp vize wolfgang kubicki
dir vorgestern in unserem großen bild
xxl esther view gesagt hat und wir
wollen noch mal ganz kurz reinhören
also man würde ihn neuen so sagen die
spacken oder dumpfbacke ist
ja nicht nur hier sondern das weiß kann
auch also auch die maloche aus dem aus
leverkusen und bochum da wo er
kandidiert sie sagen auch das ist keine
mehr von uns der höhe dürfen vor allem
die krähen wir dürfen nichts
fußballstadion
ende gelände
der kubicki wie er leibt und lebt
trotzdem hat er ja vorher auch gesagt
dass er höchsten respekt eigentlich hat
für lauterbach und sehr gut mit dem
unter umgehen kann trotzdem der ist
stinksauer wir sehen sie für den vize
präsidenten des deutschen bundestages
eine unwürdige einlassung ja es geht
dann weiter ich wüsste auch was über
herrn kubicki gesagt wird aber ich
erreiche noch mediale präsenz ohne dass
sich kollegen beleidige hier sieht man
es auch die schlagzeile riesen zoff
stinksauer
also ich glaube dass dieser streit
eigentlich zeigt wie sehr die nerven am
ende sind das die leute nicht mehr
länger gegängelt werden wollen dass
corona vorbei sein muss dass wir darüber
sprechen müssen wie natürlich mehr
menschen geimpft werden können aber
nicht länger darüber sprechen dürfen was
ist vielleicht für maßnahmen geben
könnte im herbst das ist ja das gefühl
dass man momentan bekommt dass
möglicherweise der gesundheitsminister
wer das auch immer wiederum ist
möglicherweise karl lauterbach werde die
spd diese wahl gewinnen sollte und das
ist das was man dort sieht zwischen den
beiden eigentlich verstehen die sich
ganz gut ich habe mit beiden zusammen
gesessen beide können eigentlich
argumente austauschen aber das an
wolfgang kubicki sagt ja in der kneipe
sagt der oder die das über karl
lauterbach und karl lauterbach dann
sofort reagiert bei twitter und sagt wie
kann das sein dass wolfgang kubicki als
vize bundestagspräsident so etwas sagt
das zeigt was bei corona kaputtgegangen
ist das zeigt sozusagen das irgendwie
wie endlich ein raus brauchen wir müssen
raus aus diesen
debatten wir müssen raus aus den
maßnahmen wir brauchen den freedom day
und es ist wichtig dass die nächste
regierung in den koalitionsvertrag rein
schreibt wann es vorbei ist ich glaube
das ist ganz entscheidend war auch sehr
erstaunlich da waren wir alle sehr
baftas wolfgang kubicki die auch
verraten hat dass er sich selbst gar
nicht an die maßnahmen gehalten hat
indem lockdown er saß selbst mit
freunden zusammen ist sogar in die
kneipe gegangen ich glaube das war eine
total ehrliche antwort von wolfgang
kubicki das geht glaube ich vielen in
deutschland so die gesamte irgendwann
haben wir uns nicht mehr dran gehalten
und wolfgang kubicki hat einfach
ausgesprochen was glaube ich auch den
einen oder anderen anderen politiker
angeht der gesagt hat ich habe mich auch
nicht daran gehalten der sich aber nicht
traut das zu sagen also natürlich kann
man darüber debattieren wie es sein kann
dass war für ein kubicki wo die fdp
mitregiert wo der fdp
gesundheitsminister von der fdp kommt in
schleswig holstein dann sagt okay ich
habe mich nicht dran gehalten auf der
anderen seite ist es sehr volksnah weil
die leute am ende kein bock mehr hat
[Musik]